this is a production of cornell
university
so thank you today i'm going to be
talking about
the chemical language of fungi so indeed
as
gary was basically telling you we spent
a lot of time
my whole life honestly that is my career
i'm looking working with fungi and
specializing actually quite a bit on the
signals that fungi make
a lot of them being what are known as
secondary metabolites
these are compounds that most people
actually know about even though they
don't know they know about it
many of the pigments that fungi make and
you can see in the spores in this
particular
slide here are melanins that often
are natural products of a certain
chemical class
oh i see if you go over to this slide
so when we think about communication and
really this entire lecture is now
about communication um fungal chemicals
this is something we learn when we're i
don't know
in first grade or preschool we have eyes
ears nose
mouth and touch well what do fungi
have fungi
actually share a lot of
perception as us they don't have a nose
per se or a mouth per se
but they do perceive chemicals
much the same way that analogously
to let's say people with their smell and
taste
fungi do have vision as well and they do
have touch responses i'm not sure about
hearing
but today we're going to talk about
chemicals
so most of the chemicals that fungi
make are known as natural products or
secondary metabolites
and these compounds are all derived from
primary metabolites for example
we can have acyl coas that all organisms
make they go
to make fatty acids for example or your
or membrane
steriles fungi and bacteria
and plants i could say as well can
take these natural on these acyl coas
they use them for primary metabolism but
they also incorporate them
into two big chemical classes called
polyketides
and through the valinate pathway into
terpenes
and then amino acids which of course
fungi are going to use just as we do for
our
canonical proteins they also will take
these amino acids
and they will make short peptides they
are known mostly as non-ribosomal
peptides also
in our lab um we found a in a
collaboration with frank schrader's lab
at cornell
we characterize a new chemical class and
fungi called us
cyanides now these are the
typical secondary metabolites people now
know pretty well
honestly this is pretty well known by
many people
there's big efforts for mining fungal
genomes
to get these for new drugs and in fact
we do quite a bit of that in our lab
as well though i won't touch on that
aspect of our research
all of these complex natural products
here are
almost invariably found in a
biosynthetic
gene cluster and this arrangement
has been very useful in the
bioinformatics study of
fungal natural products because
typically
in biosynthetic gene clusters you'll
have the synthase
that makes the particular chemical class
for example
polyketides are produced by polyketide
synthases
terpene cyclases or terpene synthetases
make these compounds and non-ribosomal
peptide synthases
are responsible for making these
metabolites
the amino acid sequence in these
synthases are
is pretty conserved so you can actually
find them
quite easily using various algorithms
now in a biosynthetic gene cluster
there's also typically
two to 15 tailoring enzymes
and these will be enzymes they're very
critical too because they'll take that
backbone that's derived from let's say
the polyketide synthase and be
responsible for
adding different moieties such as
let's say a methyl group or
um
we'll put in a
a pemerase and change the or
oxygen group so these are really
important um
and a biosynthetic gene cluster will
often but not always have a
transcription factor that's specific
to activate the expression of the other
genes in the cluster
there will often be a protective gene
because some of these compounds are
anti-fungal
a good example is gliotoxin made by
aspergillus fema goddess
it is an antifungal um so
the fungus itself has to find a way to
protect itself and it has an enzyme in
the pathway that actually will
cleave the gliotoxin to a more harmless
compound
and there will be hypothetical genes so
these are
canonical secondary metabolites that are
produced from biosynthetic gene clusters
but not all of our secondary metabolites
are coming from biosynthetic gene
clusters and today i'm going to present
two of our latest stories all involving
secondary metabolites
but one of them is more simple
our first story is a story
of self-communication
somewhat analogous to the paracrine or
autocrine
signaling that some of you might be
familiar with with
let's say in our
in immunology so
fungi have to know when to develop you
know you'll have a
an aspergillus species you have a small
resting spore it swells it has to
germinate
um the journaling then forms and it has
to branch and
you get heavy branching and then you'll
get development of the canadian four
so i'm going to be talking about a small
metabolite a secondary metabolite called
an oxylic bin
that actually is a signal for branching
the second story is going to turn to the
more canonical natural
products and not just fungal
biosynthetic gene clusters
oops let me sorry this is a very finicky
little mouse here
but also will involve some bacterial
natural products and the
crosstalk between fungi and bacteria
but let's start with this first story
on branching and fungi
this started long ago this uh
it has its roots in plant pathology as
do does
story two which i think is fitting for
the audience
many years ago i got really interested
in understanding how the seed pathogen
aspergillus flavus
invades seed aspergillus flavus produces
aflatoxin which is the most potent
carcinogen known to humankind and you
might think of all aspergilli as being
oh they're saprophytic they'll grow on
anything but actually that's not really
true
so aspergillus are not too
they preferably like certain
i would say crops flavus grows on
seed and it prefers oil seed and i
became really interested in
trying to ask why is the oil seed the
preferable crop
at the time i was familiar with some
plant
studies where certain
fatty acids oxygenated fatty acids
called oxylipins were involved in
plant defense response to various
pathogens these oxylipins are considered
secondary metabolites
although they're simply made by
enzymatic action
on saturated i mean on unsaturated fatty
acids
well the time i started um this study
i became aware from another lab that
aspergillus species
make these oxylipins which are sort of
similar
somewhat in um structure to the plant
oxylipins
so one of the and they were already
named by um
another the the lab that found them as
psi factors
that name isn't really important they
use that name for because it was
precocious
sexual induction so it was known that
aspergilli made these and they were
involved in development of the fungus
i was interested in finding the enzymes
that made the psi
factors and
oh by the way let me ask can you see the
arrow when i move the arrow
anybody yes okay great so
i knew that the plant enzyme that made
these oxy lip bins for plants
were um lipoxygenases so
i found in the genome of the fungus
several
and my student actually demetrius
giannis is the one who really
was great in finding all these these
oxygenases
called ppos and they would make
and we found out that they made these uh
oxylipins and aspergillus
now i'm not going to go through all this
we had many many papers
um but the bottom line is this is that
we found that these
ppo enzymes that make the oxygenases if
you would delete them or
overexpress them you would actually
change the developmental program of the
fungus
here's a wild type aspergillus schnitzel
lens if you deleted ppoa you got
much more asexual growth and no sexual
whereas if you deleted ppoc
you would get the sexual development
this is a clay stathesium
the sexual fruiting body of aspergil
asparagines and less
asexual spores we also went on to find
that
when you added plant sec plant oxylipins
to fungal cultures it would change the
development of the fungus
and when we would take human um
oxylipins because humans make
prostaglandins and leukotrienes very
similar to
another type of oxylipin they would also
change the developmental plan
of the fungus so we ended up
hypothesizing and
putting forth several papers that we
felt that
oxylipins were signals cross-kingdom
signals that acted in a quorum sensing
manner with fungi
to change development now we could only
get
so far with all this research because
something that held us back
is that we were unable to procure enough
of the fungal oxylipins
no company sells them and it's very very
hard
to purify enough of them to do very good
work with fungi
however we there was a breakthrough that
occurred and now i'm going to take you
right into the depths of story
one but i'm starting with a
map of the world because story one has a
covet story that i thought concerning
the times you might be interested
this paper on where we actually have
found how one of the fungal oxylipins
actually promotes branching and fungi is
um a first author paper of my student
uh oh sorry i'm feeling
uh i'm thinking of coven and what she
went through
um mignow who graduated okay she has
graduated and she did great
what happened is she submitted her paper
to nature
um last christmas and of course we knew
it if it even went through we'd have to
do
gazillion uh morris studies uh
tests to actually get it published so
she asked if she could go
home to visit her parents for chinese
new year
i said sure you know why don't you do
that so she goes in january you know
what's happening here
and couldn't come back because the covid
um
situation in wuhan though she did not
live in wuhan
she went in january and she was only
able to get
back to wisconsin
to in july two weeks before her phd
defense
meanwhile we got the paper back um
nature said no we like it but why don't
you um it's
it's not quite nature we're going to
pass you on to nature communications
which we said okay that's a good one too
and of course
we had so much work that had to be done
in the laboratory
and there was mignow in china
so we actually uh
very proud of my lab
she communicated with everybody in the
lab
and as a community
they got this paper together and it's
been published in nature communication
anyways uh what a world we have
so the highlight is and let me show you
how we got to this
is that she found and the many people on
the paper
a specific oxylipin that aspergillus
makes and its specific
job is to induce branching so how did
she find this
one thing we did we're very particularly
interested in the ppo oxygenases because
when you delete ppoa you have a
phenotype with the fungus
so she grew up the fungus and she asked
what oxylipins do
we find so ppo a makes two oxylipins one
called
eight hoe this is derived from linoleic
acid and one is five eight dihold
and when she looked at fungal biomass
and the supernatant she could see that
5 8 was the most dominant and it was
also secreted
so we thought oh well let's see what 5 8
does
we are able to get migs of 5 8 because
another lab
had been able to purify it and express
an e coli
so we were ready to go and what does 5 8
do
you can see i have some nice movies but
they were so big i'm just going to show
you these um shots here
as you add more and more 5 8 into the
culture of the fungus and at
physiological
levels you can see there's an increase
in branching
and here we have the branches for for
100 microns of
length of hyphae we also
found that you could visualize this here
you see here
by staining with calciflora white which
stains the chitin
and you could see there's more septic
too commonly when you have a branch
not always but commonly you'll have a
septa laden here
and here you can see that indeed we had
a smaller septal distance when you're
treated with this metabolite
we then asked well are there other
compounds that could induce branching
there had been published in nature
about 15 years ago the finding that
plant a plant secondary metabolite
called a
strigolactone and this is just a
variation of the strugolatone
will induce branching and arbuscular
mycorrhizae but just in those
fungi and so we thought well we'd better
check it because we hadn't found another
chemical
and it did nothing it actually did not
induce branching and aspergills
that seems to be specific for the
mycorrhizae
so what we next did is we bought or
had our collaborator uh ernst oli um
send us my new amounts of different um
oxylipins
and what you see here these top
oxylipins are all
vertebrate oxylipins and then
these three right here are from fungi
this one is from magnaportha aspergillus
and another aspergillus one
and what we found of these oxylipins we
looked at
the branching okay i didn't want to get
to that right yet
the branching was specific to these
fungal oxylipins
and more than one oxylapin could induce
branching it
perhaps um we still don't know exactly
if it's due to the two hydroxyls but
this is really interesting
so specifically because we knew other
fungi made these and magnapurtha
grisei the leaf rice
blast fungus made eight we asked well
is this branching just um response
uh a response that only aspergillus fema
dot
fema goddess um makes or their other
fungi so we looked at a a few
other fungi and we found that one other
um pathogen aspergillose flavous also
significantly branches when exposed to
the phybate
but the other fungi we looked at and you
know it's not we didn't look at that
many
did not um including magnaportha we
didn't see a significant difference
in branching however we were bowled over
because any time you added 5
8 8-diode to magnaportha
you immediately got apres psoria
formation
and for those of you who are plant
pathologists you know right away the
aprisoria
are the structures that magnaportha
needs to
penetrate plants something we will be
looking at further
so we found that this compound actually
was a developmental signal for
many fungi
because we knew that oxylipins were
perceived from
by g protein couple receptors the next
thing we did was take a library that
we'd made
some years ago an aspergillus flavus
where
we had deleted the canonical
g-protein-coupled receptors of
aspergillus flavus
so if you look right here you can see
again with wild-type when you added
5-8-diode
to aspergillus flavus you had an
increase in branching
and we tested all of these g protein
coupled receptors
and we found three there where there was
not
a response or not a significant response
to the 5 8. what was particularly
interesting that
two of these g protein coupled receptors
gprc
and gprg we had shown earlier
many years earlier to be necessary for
responding
to plant oxylipins so
we believe that these particular
receptors on the surface of the fungus
are involved in perceiving
the fungus's own metabolite
now we were fortunate enough as i say to
have enough of this 5 8 that we
actually went to where we really wanted
to go in the first place
and that was rna seek
actually i had no idea what rna sequence
when i was starting the study because it
wasn't um
had not been when i started working with
oxylipins because it had not been a
technology at the time
but it's a very powerful one as you know
we found that treatment with 5 8 and we
did a 30 minute and 120 minute
study because we thought this is it's a
signal things are going to happen right
away and they did we had many many genes
that were
significantly differentially regulated
enough
that we decided what we would do is just
look at the transcription factors
that are differentially regulated this
is all an aspergillus fumagotis now
we found 35 transcription factors that
were differentially regulated
significantly differentially regulated
now 35 is a lot
but luckily there is a transcription
factor
deletion library in aspergeals fema
goddess
um headed by dr michael bromley and so
michael joined our study and we tested
these 35
several times and we came down where
mignow found that there were actually
three of these transcription factors
that one deleted did not respond to 5 8
and you can see one for example right
here is one the step one did not respond
this one barely responded these two did
not respond and in fact they actually
had an abnormal branching phenotype
so after finding these three genes she
actually went
and extracted rna again just to
confirm the rna seek results
and you can see that two of the genes i
just have the transcription factor names
hgo5oz or one zero
was induced by five eight uh this one
was induced by five eight and two were
repressed by 5 8. so
what look what did these uh what were
the phenotypes when you looked at them
these were the five deletion strains
that did not respond normally
to 5 8. so here's the wild type
the ethanol carrier and the 5 8 and you
can see the higher branching
and this particular meta this particular
mutant
you can say it was abnormal even as a
without treatment and it did not respond
it was a
hypo brancher a hypobrancher and hyper
branchers
so we became really interested in
exploring these
a little further especially the two
that had the most significant response
and what we did let me just go back here
again
is oftentimes with a transcription
factor
if you over express it
you can have the opposite phenotype as
when you delete it not always but
sometimes so we said
well let's take this strain which when
you delete it has a
hypo branching and see if we get a hyper
brancher
or likewise what if we take a
hyperbrancher
and when we overexpress it do we get a
hypobrancher
because we reasoned that if you had the
exact opposite phenotype
you actually find a transcription factor
that was
very key in regulating branching
and we found one of those what we found
is this particular
gene 082490 when you overexpressed it
let me just go back again this is our
favorite gene
when you delete it it's a hypo brancher
and when you over express it it's a
hyper brancher
so we are very um thrilled to find this
transcription factor through this
methodology
it turns out had been given a name
before
as zfpa also there had been no research
really focused on this
it was just um given that name from a
microarray study from another lab
and so what we proposed here we end this
study as we
have found to our knowledge the very
first transcription factor
that regulates branching and fungi and
that is a downstream
target of fungal oxylipins
where the signal is mediated through
a g protein one or more
g-protein-coupled receptors
furthermore we believe that this
is um very important as
not only an autocrine signal for the
fungus itself
what but likely paracrine signaling
between microbes or
host tissue that it grows next to what
we're doing right now one of our
big stories here and interests is we
know that
the immune system this is a macrophage
and a neutrophil
that they also make oxylipins such as um
prostaglandins and leukotrienes that are
really important in inflammation
and we suspect and are now um
interrogating the
question are the oxylipins from the
aspergillus fema goddess impacting
immune cell response and are oxylipins
from the immune cell actually impacting
the fungus by controlling branching
what's the fungus inside
we're also really interested um we're
inviting a magnapurtha person to work
with us
on asking could the plant the rice
oxylipins
actually be involved and recognized by
magnaportha
as part of the signal to make a
aprisorium so that is our
story number one
story number two is now going to
move into our interests in natural
product signaling between fungi and
bacteria
and the consequences of that signaling
we're
returning to canonical secondary
metabolites now
we actually have three projects in the
lab
um one where we're looking at the soil
microbiome or i could even say plant
microbiome with uh
plant pathogens one the lung microbiome
with human pathogens
and then in a collaboration with ben
wolfe at tufts university the
interesting cheese microbiome with uh
the fungi and bacteria that grow in
cheese rinds
for the sake of time i'm going to focus
just on the first one today
so how did this get started
we're looking at a bacterium called
ralstonia solanaceaem a very famous wilt
pathogen of
many plants and then the mica toxin
producing fusarium and aspergillus
strains
okay so this story actually started a
little
accidentally as many studies do
when i first moved to wisconsin
before the building that i now am um
lodged in is was built i shared a lab in
the plant pathology
building with dr caitlin allen who is
very um
a world leader on the bacterium rostonia
solanaceae arum
and of course we are working with
aspergillus and fusarium and
the story goes that sometimes there'd be
little contamination of an
aspergillus spore that went into raw
stolen raw
raw estonia play and things happen you
could see
that the two microbes responded to each
other
many years later we know what's
happening
between these organisms and
the response of these organisms to each
other is in part
mediated by three secondary metabolites
a lipopeptide we call rosyllomycin made
by the bacterium
a non-ribosomal peptide we call
imazoquin made by aspergillus flavus
and a polyketide made by fiserium
species called by cavern
i want to put a shout out these are
papers are published i won't go into
them into great detail
a shout out to our excellent
collaboration with dr frank schrader's
lab
on these projects
so aside
from these natural products there's a
there is a also a visual response when
these organisms grow each other and this
is really important for this story
here we have uh rawstonia growing
and here we have aspergillus flavus
growing and if you look at this
particular plate where they're very
close to each other
you can see that there's these bumps
all over the mycelium of the fungus
these bumps were so
big that you can see it with the
dissecting scope and
maybe even without the dissecting scope
if you can squint
what we found is that the fungus was
producing chlamydospores
when it grew near the bacterium
a chlamydospore for those who are not
familiar is a very large
resistant spore to environmental
stresses
it can either grow within the mycelium
intercalary or
terminally it's characterized by a very
thick cell wall with a lot of chitin in
it and
usually is a lot of new nuclei in it
well we were really pretty surprised to
see this
because aspergillus is not known for
making clematis spores
some fungi make a lot but most really
weren't known
so when we found this we thought there
was something that the bacterium was
producing
that was involved
the other thing and we'll get to that in
one second but the other thing we became
really interested in
was wow these chlamydospores are so big
could
the bacteria possibly be going in so we
got a
gfp labeled strain from dr allen
and we found that indeed the bacteria
would induce the chlamydospores and then
go inside and this is a
movie of a z-stack we saw some clematis
four had hundreds
some had thousands of
bacteria in it so how uh
did the bacterium induces chlamydia
spores
that became our next query and
here let's go to the next slide we found
that it was
due to a lipopeptide that the bacterium
made
i'm not going to go through all the
story on this um it's
it's published but the bacteria makes a
lipopeptide called raw solomycin
it has anti-fungal effects at high
concentrations
and it induces the formation of the
chlamydospores and the bacterium then
enter
the chlamydospores if you delete the
genes and the bacterium
so you no longer have the lipopeptide
there's no antifungal effect and the
hyphae is
nice and pristine with no clematis
spores
this seemed to us at the time that
perhaps um
not necessarily something that was
helpful for the fungus or oh well i i
guess you could
it was six and one half a dozen of the
other there's that anti-fungal effect
but chlamydospores are spores that
um are very resistant to abiotic
stresses
cold heat acceptor but if a lot of
bacteria go in it is that
going to obfuscicate
the i would say the advantage of making
these
so we wanted to ask what does the fungus
do
when confronted with ralph solomycin and
here again we um
actually did another rna-seq where we
grew the fungus either with uh
russell amycin present or without
rosolomycin and we looked
for genes that were significantly up or
down regulated
and one was very interesting to us was a
secondary metabolite gene cluster that
is normally never expressed
to high degrees in the fungus and it was
but it to some degree but it was down
regulated by raw solomycin
we're able to characterize this as this
non-ribosomal peptide called
emazoquin and um to make a long story
short from this particular paper
we found that emisoquins are actually
important for quick
spore germinatement germination and
aspergillus
and they inhibit the growth of raw
solamycin
whereas raw solamycin made by ralstonia
actually inhibits
the expression of this compound that
inhibits the growth of the bacterium
so this is a really interesting
antagonism between
two natural products that respond to
each other
in this case it seemed like perhaps in
favor of the
bacterium now as we are working on this
we notice that in the fusion species the
chlamydospores which are
smaller than aspergills but many of them
all turned red just about here's one
that's not red yet but it will turn red
and here's the bacterium it also enters
inside this chlamydosporo the bacterium
goes in
all chlamydospores so we wondered what
this
red compound was and um
we were able to do some imaging and
found out that this
compound was a fungal
polyketide known as by cavern it had
already been discovered but we
nobody had shown that it was responsive
to
raw solomycin you can see here that this
treatment where we have the fungus in
the bacterium
the bicavern is really produced in great
amounts right at the edge
where the chlamydospores are formed
what we found is that opposite of
aspergillus
that
keeps flicking very quickly here um
we found that this by cavern gene
cluster is actually induced by
rossolomycin and
we thought maybe this was giving the
fungus some advantage
so we deleted the bicavern genes in
fusarium
and then we looked at rawstonia growth
and confrontation with wild-type
fusarium
or a few serum that lack by cavern and
you can see that actually
the the bacterium grew
better when there was no bicarbonate
this one is a little complex here um
right here oh my goodness gracious
um we also showed that raw solomycin
induced as i said by cavern production
and fusarium
one thing that's really interesting is
by cavern is always known to be
inhibited by high nitrogen but if you
add raw
uh raw solamycin it will allow the
fungus to make more by cavern
and here we you can see the vicarin
genes are induced when you add raw solar
mycin
so we went on to show then
that by cavern oh i showed you this a
little earlier
that by cavern reduced rawstonia growth
this is with
whole extracts of the fungus but we also
got purified by cavern and showed that
purified by cavern actually
reduced bacterial growth so we concluded
from this particular interaction
that yes the um in this case raw stony
induced the chlamydia spores infusion
just as it does in every fungus and the
bacteria would enter
but in the case of fusarium it actually
would induce the production
of a polyketide only in the
chlamydosport where the bacteria entered
and reduced the population
the number of bacteria
so these studies are all published
and i want to end though with a
continuation of this work
by another student in the lab
nandita venkatesh so just to reiterate
again i i think i'd mention that
ralstonia of course is a wilt pathogen
but so is fusarium
so one thing that nandita has been
looking at is
well what happens when you have these
two
pathogens together knowing that
rawstonia can actually enter a
chlamydosporo of fusarium at least in
the laboratory
and what is by cavern doing so
this is work that is um in preparation
by
mandita one thing that
we found is that when you have raw
stonya it does kill tomatoes immediately
fucerimoxyspring is a slower killer but
it will eventually but when you mix them
together it looked more like a
fusarium phenotype
and what she has found and we're still
doing some work on this
is that for reasons yet to be explained
when you mix
fusarium and rawstonia together you
actually reduce the high severe
severity of a bacterial wilt
disease but it is a little bit more than
the fungus by itself
and then she went ahead to do a
co-culture with ralstonia
and the bicavern mutant of fusarium
and there's actually a bit more will so
it
appears that by cavern actually
is reducing to some degree the severity
of
wilt disease by rostonia
we then um she's not quite finished with
this yet but
we started to ask well okay is there any
benefit
to the bacterium
when it's in the soil where presumably
it is
with the fusarium and so
the we have found that in this little
mini winter
study that the ralstonia
does grow better when fucerum is there
which we
hypothesize is because of the
ability to enter and survive in the
chlamydospores
of the fungus now to really get
deep into understanding what's happening
with this interaction with the
bacterium and the chlamydospores
indeed has gotten really much further
and we're very shortly to submit this
work
here is just a time lapse where you can
see
the chlamydospores forming in fungal
mycelium
when it's added to russell when raw
solomycin is added
nandita found it takes minimal amounts
of rascola mycin way less than the
bacteria makes to induce these
chlamydospores here you can see it
what um way down at this
molarity we still get significant
numbers of raw solar mice of
chlamydospores and the bacteria makes a
much higher amount than this
so we first wanted to see okay you know
how many chlamydospores do you get and
what molarity of russell mycen do you
need
and then what nandita did is she
developed a
z-stacking methodology so she could
see the bacteria going inside the
chlamydospore
and why she did this you can see right
here is we had a hypothesis that
oh well if oscillomycin is in the soil
could other bacteria get inside the
fungus or is it limited to
raw solar mice ralstonia and she found
a lot of bacteria could go inside the
chlamydia spores here we have
pseudomonas originosa opportunistic
human pathogen
and herba spirulium which is a nitrogen
fixing bacterium
what she did is went through and
examined as many gram-negative and
gram-positive bacteria that we could
find from researchers in the lab
and we have a little story here
she found we were able to look at three
gram positive
they never enter the chlamydis spore
and then she looked at five different
gram negatives and all
except for this one bacillus will enter
the climatospore
so it seemed to be that many a broad
range of these bacteria
and what was interesting to us is when
she looked at these and looked at a
phylogenetic tree
the fungi that went inside the chlamydia
spore are
not were never known to be
endo fungal bacteria before so in red
are the known endofungal bacteria
but we found that rawstonia
herbaspirelium
e coli and pseudomonas also went inside
we believe this is the first time it um
there's evidence for these fungi to
enter bacteria
so is this something that's just limited
to raw solomycin
um nandita looked in the literature and
she found that there's many lipopeptides
and here's just some of them
that have been reported in the
literature to induce chlamydospores
so we started to think could this
actually be widespread
and what we are able to do she's able to
do
is get a um isolated bacillus
the wild type that made um fingerson
that
had been shown to induce chlamydia
spores and one that was deleted for
producing fingerson and we found that
indeed when you had fingerson and this
happens to be with a flavus and
pseudomonas originosa we get
chlamydospores and pseudomonas
enters inside the chlamydis spores this
is getting very exciting to us ah
there's a lot going on here maybe this
is very common there's a lot of
lipopeptides a lot of bacteria
a lot of bacteria going inside
the next thing she wanted to ask was
well
will a clematis spore only house one
bacterium or could there be more than
one bacterium
so this is a case where we either she
either co-inf um
co-cultured ralstonia and aspergil
salone or
pseudomonas and aspergillus or both
ralstonia and pseudomonas
and what we find is they both go inside
she did note that when they were
introduced
sort of would change the ver the ratio
of how much each bacterium
so here we have a situation in e where
we just had the fungus and rostonia
and um she waited a certain time period
and found about fifteen percent of the
clematis spores were colonized
when she co-incubated roth ralstoni and
pseudomonas
um she found and now she's just counting
rostonia
that there was an increase in the number
of ralstonia
that were inside the clematis force she
then
did the same experiment but she allowed
pseudomonas
to arrive at the
fungal court earlier than rostonia and
when she did that
we saw an increase in the number of
pseudomonas so we think that
obviously more than one bacterium can go
inside the
chlamydosport but the relative amount of
which bacterium is there might depend on
which bacterium
arrive first the last thing she looked
at
is asked does this colonization
really um does it give any advantage to
the bacterium
we had a little hint earlier that it did
but she wanted to look at this a little
bit further under controlled
experimentation
and here we have an example of
the impact growing
the bacterium with the funguses under
starvation conditions
so what she did here let's just look at
the raw
ralstonian flavous interaction
she would grow the bacterium
either a wild type bacterium that made
raw solomycin or this one that does not
make real solomycin so no chlamydospores
and when she grew them in a situation
where there was
lots of nutrients for the bacterium
both the wild-type bacterium and the um
the bacterium lacking raw solomycin grew
equally
with aspergillus flavous however when
she grew them
under a situation where there was no
nutrients under starvation
you can see here that the bacterium that
actually made roscolomycin and could
therefore go into chlamydospores
grew much better than the poor bacterium
without a lipopeptide
she found exactly the same thing with
pseudomonas originosa
so this suggested to us that the
bacterium actually does receive
some benefit by being able to enter
inside the back
inside the chlamydospore
so i gave you a lot of what she has um
worked on there's some other tests she
did but i
would like to conclude with this second
story right now
by saying what we think is happening we
believe that this is
widespread in nature um that actually
chlamydif spore formation in fungi is
induced by
lipopeptides that are made by many
bacteria
it allows bacteria one or more than one
to enter inside a
fungal chlamydospore it will protect
them in different environments and we
we think of the soil we started with
soil but of course
all the microbes we were working with
are actually those that could be found
in the human microbiome or in even
other places such as the cheese
microbiome and
we are now about as i say to submit this
that we believe that we should consider
the
chlamydospore as having its own
bacterial microbiome inside
it so i
will uh stop with those two stories i i
do have more but i'm conscious of the
time here
so i just want to end this talk and show
you what
it looks like when there is no covavirus
at madison which we hope will come back
again
um i show in red the two people who
really actually did most of the work
menial for the oxylipid branching
signaling and nandita for this really
exciting
bacterial fungal microbiome
listed in yellow are those that helped
menial during our
coven crisis i also want to shout out to
frank
schrader because a lot of the work that
i mentioned some of our earlier work has
been crucial for helping
and with menial also dr um oli
nupsila sweden who actually made some
oxylippins for us and
dave bibi who helped us with some
microfluidic devices
and with that i'm happy to take
any questions nancy thank you very much
what a terrific
seminar there we really appreciate it so
uh i'm sure they'll
i don't see anything in the chat room
yet but i'd encourage anybody to
put your questions in the chat room
nancy always proud of you
today is no exception
um regarding the first story
and the transcription factor induced
by the oxylipin yes do you have
any idea about the
conservation of that uh
transcription factor across fungi
um we do have a little bit of an idea
about that it's um
honestly we looked in aspergillus flavus
and it's there so one of the next
studies will be to see if it also
regulates branching there
it does seem to be um pretty good
homologs and ascomyces
so it'd be really interesting to look in
some other fungi to see
what it does with them yeah and
are there any other morphological
developmental effects other than
branching and possibly across orion
yes there are and i'm glad you asked
that
um what i didn't tell you is that this
is a signal for
inducing secondary metabolism too
we're really excited about that we um
hypothesize well so a lot of the the
canonical secondary metabolites
um we believe um there's lots of
evidence to suggest
well some evidence that they're
associated with the endocytic pathway
and we think they're associated with the
growing tips and septa
and so we're we will be exploring that
further
calcium signaling too there's a lot of
calcium signaling
genes that are upregulated
gary are you seeing questions yes there
are
a couple questions here so uh you've got
a couple of
applauses i shall say uh there's a
question here
how uh from saeed um how
will uh rastonia be freed from the
clemence four
can it easily go in and out or does it
need to await
germination of the clematis or to
escape oh that's an excellent question
and i don't have
an 100 answer for this
now nandita has sometimes but sometimes
not
seen as the fungus germinates the
bacterium traveling through the hyphae
not all the time but sometimes i suspect
that
this does happen on occasion so when
that chlamydosport germinates and
i should break oh man you like get 10 to
15 germ tubes coming out of it it's so
big
that the bacteria can go out that way
maybe it can also go out through cell
wall remodeling too
with that we don't know yet so a
follow-up question there
uh from uh raleigh is any ideas on how
the bacteria
enter the spore and then can you
speculate why gram
positives cannot gain access
yeah um so
we have some ideas that we want to
follow up on
um i don't know if nandita will she does
want to graduate but
we're wondering if some of the type 3 or
some of the secretion systems in the
bacteria are important
so gram positive and gram nega have have
different
secretion systems maybe that's part of
it
the gram positives um
i don't think this is why it stops them
from going inside
but they do we have some nice pictures
where they like to stick on the hyphy on
the outside of the fungus but
that shouldn't preclude them we're
thinking it might have something to do
with these
uh secretion systems of the bacteria
great and and maria harrison asked a
very similar question
stephen higgins said you get a great
talk
uh obviously not all raw estonia enter
the clementosport
are there any nutrient signals in these
spores that attract some ralstonia over
others
we don't know that
one thing we want to ask in the future
is
the chlamydospores have a lot of lipid
bodies in them
they're just chock full of lipids and
we're guessing the bacteria
might be living off of the lipid body so
we want to
there's several ways we could address
that question
but we don't have anything specific
right now
i don't see any other questions in there
right now i want to remind you nancy
that this your talk has been recorded so
we'll be sure to get you that recording
okay great use for other occasions okay
well that
that sounds wonderful and i'm sure i
know i'm meeting with some of the
postdocs and grad
students yeah so i see that you're right
on the button there it's supposed to
start at 1 45 but what i
why don't i suggest that uh you'll need
a little bit of a break
and then ask ask the students and post
docs to
rejoin you um at the zoom link that was
provided to them
okay oh sorry i think i went over there
i will um
join fox and grad students very shortly
so let's give a round of virtual
applause for uh
for nancy here thank you very much nancy
thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web
at cornell.edu